another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the scp foundation  challenge anyone to a duel and then give  them as cp 572. challenging other  foundation personnel to a duel is a  terrible idea at the best of times  that's how we lost dr hamilton but it  becomes especially farcical with scp-572  572 is a shoddy and poorly weighted  katana that to anyone using it appears  to be a blade of awesome power that  drives them to perform ill-considered  and dangerous stunts these often result  in the injury of themselves or others  until the sword is taken from them or  they're knocked out it causes major  headaches for the foundation whenever  it's used but of course dr bright thinks  it's hilarious